[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN MCDOWELL: Joining me today
is Oliver Tweedie from Sky,
director of data engineering.
And today we're
going to be talking
through real-time
streaming analytics
with Dataflow, common
use cases, and patterns.
But before we dive
straight into patterns,
it's important to
understand streaming
and why it matters and
a couple of the things
that the Apache Beam
SDK and Dataflow do
to solve some of the common
problems that you may run into.
So we can have data
that we're processing.
And that data can be big.
For instance, we can be
processing from gigabytes
to terabytes.
It could be really, really big.
So we may have huge
amounts of data
that we want to process
every day and multiple days
that we want to process.
And that data can also
be infinitely big.
So we may have streaming data
that's constantly coming.
It never stops.
And this gives a
problem with processing,
especially with unknown delays.
So one of the more difficult
things with unbounded data
is unknown delays.
So assuming that every record
has an event timestamp,
hopefully we would see
the record show up shortly
after the event that occurred.
So we're going to
look over here.
The red record here
happened at 8:00 AM.
And it showed up in the
system shortly after.
The yellow record
happened at 8:00 AM
and showed up in the
system slightly delayed.
But then we have this
green record over here
that has an event
time stamp of 8:00 AM,
but showed up at 2:30, which
is about a six-hour delay.
And there are several reasons
why these delays may happen.
The most common case is
actually mobile devices.
So with mobile devices,
you can imagine
that you get on a plane,
you turn your phone
onto airplane mode,
you play a game
on your mobile device
the entire plane ride.
And when you get off, you
turn your airplane mode off
and all those events
shoot up to the cloud.
And so you get all these events
into your data pipeline all at
once because we
had no connectivity
during that period.
Now if we are doing element
wise transforms, such as just
filtering out for the
yellow records here,
that's relatively simple.
We don't care about
processing time or event time.
Its easy because its a
continuous transform.
But when we get to grouping data
via processing time windows,
so let's say we want
to do an aggregation.
We want to count the number of
events that happened per user.
For batch it's easy
because it's bounded.
We just read the
input stream, and then
as soon as there's no more
data, we stop processing
and we calculate the
result and emit it.
For streaming we can't do that.
You never run out of data,
so there's no way of saying,
this is the time where I output
the count that I've seen.
So most commonly what
people want to do
is group data into
processing time windows,
or windows rather, and divide
data up into small chunks
so that they can
compute aggregations
over that chunk of time
and then output results.
So initial approach is to
use processing time windows.
Essentially when a
job sees a record,
it looks at the wall clock,
it does that for a minute,
and then outputs a record.
But what we really
may want to do
is actually group
that by event time.
So instead of viewing something
as a time on the wall clock,
viewing data as a stream,
and group by our event
timestamps within our data.
And output them as we see them.
This allows us to
perform calculations
over the event time interval
which the events have occurred.
So essentially what we do
is we take the input, which
is all the events occurring
and processing time,
we regroup them and shuffle them
to group them into event time
and calculate meaningful
analytics over our data.
So I mentioned windows.
What is a window?
A window is just a function
to divide data into chunks.
Within the Apache
Beam SDK and Dataflow,
we provide several different
window types to slice
and dice your data
in different ways.
So for instance, here's some
of the more common ones--
fixed windows and
sliding windows.
So a fixed window,
you could think of it
as processing data from like
one to two, two to three,
so on and so forth.
And so you're pretty much
dividing up your data
into time chunks and then
grouping it and providing
some aggregation on that data.
Sliding windows, you
can think of those
as overlapping fixed windows.
So an event that happened
may actually end up
in multiple different windows.
So say that I had a sliding
window that was an hour,
and it slides every
minute, I essentially
have windows that end up being
12:01 to 1:01, 12:02 to 1:02,
so on and so forth.
And so I could have a lot
of overlapping windows.
And this is useful when you're
doing things like analysis
on maybe the input
rate of the data
or calculating how
many events that I've
seen in the past
minute or 10 minutes
for a particular event type.
In Beam we also support
data-dependent windows.
So what if I wanted to group by
something that was in my event
itself?
So I want to create windows
for users, for instance.
This is what we
would call Sessions.
So every key here ends
up in a different window.
Sessions are defined by whenever
there is a burst of activity.
I want to group that into
a window for processing
and calculate
statistics over that.
And then when there's no
data for a period of time,
such as a gap, I'm going
to close that window
and fire it off.
This is a common thing you
may want to do in analytics.
And it's supported out of the
box and Dataflow and Apache
Beam.
So I've talked a little bit
about the windowing semantics
and how we would divide
our data up and maybe do
computations over it within a
real-time analytics pipeline.
But when does the
answer come out?
This is problematic
because you have
to know when to emit
the result for the data
that you're seeing
for that window.
By default, what we have is
something called a watermark.
The watermark tries
to know when we are
done with data for a window.
So if the watermark says
12 o'clock, it means,
to the best of our
knowledge, there
is no more data left
before 12 o'clock.
And we can calculate the
result and emit it downstream.
For external sources, it has
to be somewhat heuristic.
So, for instance,
for Pub/Sub, we
can actually do a read-ahead
of the Pub/Sub buffer
to essentially look at is
there any more messages left
before a certain period
of time and then know
that we can effectively
emit the results.
Now going back to the mobile
phone on a plane example,
you could have someone who
has data from 11 o'clock
on their phone.
They don't have any
internet connectivity.
And obviously we
can't know about that.
So that actually
becomes late data.
So if we look at the
heuristic watermark here,
essentially you can see that
while it does pretty well,
it doesn't catch the
nine that happens
a lot later than we expected.
For the perfect
watermark, it is perfect.
It knows about everything,
including events
that may happen in the future.
So what happens when
you have late data?
In the Beam SDK, we have
a way of saying that I
want to process late data.
You can add triggering
to your windows
to indicate you want to
process that late data.
And there are several different
ways of processing it.
So for instance, using
accumulating processing
means that if I have
late data show up,
I want to add that late data
to my previous aggregation.
So for instance, if I
was counting elements
and I had to count to 50 before,
and that the data shows up,
I give--
I fire off that late
data, and I get back
a result of 52 instead
of the original 50,
when two late elements show up.
I can also say I want
to discard late data--
or discard fired panes, rather.
So essentially if I wanted to do
this count and compute the sum,
I could have 50 elements
that show up on time.
I could have two elements
that show up late.
And as opposed to recalculating
the result and firing off 52,
I may say forget about the
50 that I had previously
calculated, I only want
to get the count of two
and discard those
previous fired panes.
So in this other
animation, you can actually
see some of our speculative
in late firings.
So in this case, the
heuristic watermark
is actually firing speculatively
for records that show up
before the watermark,
and then also catching
those late records for
a given period of time.
So we're actually
able to capture
a lot of that data
that does not show up
when we would expect it.
So that was a little bit
about streaming, and sort
of the common
challenges, and how
Dataflow and the Apache
Beam SDK helps address
some of those challenges.
For the subsequent
section, we're
actually going to talk about
building a pipeline using
some common patterns.
So from just simple
element wise transforms
to grouping aggregations
and that type stuff.
For this we're actually going
to use the scenario that I've
been alluding to previously
of capturing events
and analyzing them
for a mobile game.
So let's imagine we
have a mobile game,
and we want to build
a real-time analytics
pipeline to analyze those game
events that may be happening.
And we want our game
to be popular, too.
So we want to be able to
handle these events at scale
and be able to do
interesting things
like compute aggregations
over how many events
that we're seeing per
user or analyze the user
behavior within the game app.
We'll start out with
exactly-once processing.
So starting to build this
pipeline from the most simple
case, we may have our gaming
devices publishing up data
into Pub/Sub, then Dataflow
processing that data,
and then BigQuery
finally landing that data
into our data warehouse.
We're using Pub/Sub because it's
a reliable, globally available
message delivery service.
And we expect our game to be
popular worldwide, so why not?
Now if we're analyzing
user behavior,
duplicates which
may enter our system
may throw off our analytics.
So if I'm calculating counts,
if I'm doing averages,
if I allow duplicates
into my system,
I'm going to throw off the
analytics that I'm doing
and, thus, make them
substantially less valuable.
And this is also critical
in other industries,
such as retail or finance.
So imagine I have a POS system,
which is generating transaction
events.
I obviously wouldn't
want to double
count those transactions,
and same thing with trades
or holdings.
In this example, zooming
in onto Cloud Pub/Sub,
you may think that it
may cause a problem
because it has at-least
once delivery semantics.
So inherently by
using Pub/Sub, we
may receive duplicates
within our system.
Here the colors indicate
unique keys for the records.
So we have red, yellow,
green coming in,
and we may have duplicate
records that come out.
However, when combining
Pub/Sub with Dataflow,
we're actually able to achieve
this exactly-once semantics
within our pipeline.
And it's with relatively
little effort.
So we're going to
zoom in a little bit
on the records coming
into our pipeline.
It may look like this.
We have attributes in a payload.
That comprises the message
that's going into Pub/Sub.
Attributes are key value pairs.
You can think of it as
a header on the message.
It allows you to sort
of inspect the message
and maybe route it
in different ways
or perform other operations
without having to actually
deserialize the payload.
And the payload contains
the serialized payload
of our message.
In this case, we're
publishing JSON events up
into our Pub/Sub topic.
And you'll see that we
have a unique identifier
within the message
payload, an event ID.
So the first step to
actually processing
this in exactly-once fashion is
that we'll promote this event
ID into our attributes.
And this allows us
to instruct Dataflow
to direct to it
within our pipeline
and start deduplicating
these messages.
So we take a look at
our example pipeline
here for our game events.
It may look like the
following, so essentially we
have a Pub/Sub I/O transform.
It's reading some data
from a subscription.
And then it's passing down data
downstream to our transforms.
So the first step was
to add in that event ID
into our attributes.
Now we need to instruct Dataflow
to react to that event ID.
And that's relatively
simple here.
As opposed to just having a
very vanilla transform with just
specifying the subscription, we
add in this .withIdAttribute.
And this allows
Dataflow to know,
I'm going to look
at this event ID
and deduplicate on
that as messages
come into the pipeline.
Now this will
deduplicate messages that
are being caused by Pub/Sub.
So any messages that are
duplicated as part of Pub/Sub's
at-least once delivery
semantics will
be deduplicated automatically
within the pipeline.
There's also other
areas in which
we can receive
duplicate messages,
such as a publisher maybe
publishing a message twice.
This will also pick
that up as well,
but it will only do that
within a 10-minute window.
So we don't keep around
the event ID deduplication
table for the past 10 minutes.
So if you had a
publisher maybe going--
publishing a message
at minute one,
and then they publish the same
duplicate message at hour one,
minute one, you would then have
to account for that elsewhere
in your pipeline, such as
using a unique transform.
So we're achieving exactly-once
semantics within our pipeline.
The next thing we
may want to do is
think about how we
deal with bad data.
In order to deal with bad
data coming into our system,
we're actually going to add
some things to our architecture,
such as Pub/Sub to handle a
dead letter topic and Cloud
Functions then to alert
on messages which end up
in that dead letter topic.
So what does this look
like in actuality?
So we have this message
being published in.
You can notice that this message
is malformed in some way.
We don't have a closing
tag on our JSON object.
The event ID is no longer
in the proper format.
So we were expecting
a string, and now it
doesn't have the
quotes around it.
So by default, if this
was to enter our pipeline,
it's going to fail when we try
to parse these messages, right?
In Dataflow, we'll actually
try to reprocess those messages
forever in streaming
mode because we
don't want to lose that data.
So if that data fails and
it throws an exception
we don't want to just
drop it on the floor.
So we'll continue to
reprocess it forever
or until you tell us
what to do with it,
such as updating your
pipeline or creating
a new path within your pipeline
to deal with the bad data.
So what do we do?
We can actually edit
our ParDo function.
So each one of those
boxes is a ParDo function.
Essentially you could
think of a ParDo function
as almost like a
map in MapReduce.
ParDo function has a process
element method, where
it performs the computation.
And so, as opposed to just
performing our computation
and outputting
records, what we'll do
is we'll wrap it in
a try-catch block
and then we'll output
[? filled ?] records
for any exception to
our dead letter tag.
And that dead
letter tag allows us
to then retrieve those messages
later on in our pipeline
and then do something
with them, such as output
them to a persistent store.
So if we were to go back to our
pipeline here, in this case,
we are now redirecting
our messages
to a different location.
We're taking that
dead letter tag
and we are then routing it
to both BigQuery and Pub/Sub.
We're routing to
BigQuery and Pub/Sub
because we want our
support team to be
able to analyze those bad
data, to be able to inspect it
within BigQuery.
And then we also want
to output it to Pub/Sub
for ease of reprocessing
and alerting
within our Cloud Function.
And so in this example, this is
an example of a BigQuery table
that you may see for dead letter
processing, where we're storing
maybe the event timestamp,
the payload in bytes,
and maybe try to convert
the payload to a string
to show more data
about that payload
so someone has more context--
so the attributes, and the error
message, and the stack trays.
And this way, someone
can go in there,
see what the problem is, and
then hopefully rectify it.
So we've added handling for
bad data within our pipeline,
but we also may actually
have another case which
may cause failures, and
that is schema changes.
So for a mobile game,
imagine that we have partners
that are publishing this data.
So our partners are
publishing this data,
and they may want to update
the schema at some point.
And we need to react to
that within our pipeline.
So we may need to add additional
fields within our pipeline
dynamically.
Now we could do this
not dynamically.
We could have coordination, like
we could call up the partner
and say, we're
going to coordinate
a release on this date and have
a lot of operational overhead.
But we actually want to
dynamically handle this
because then we're free from
that operational overhead
of having to manage it.
So looking back at
our messages, we
may have the message
on the left, which
is the yellow message, which is
coming in just as we expected
in the schema that we expected.
But we also may have a
message on the right,
like the green message here,
that has an additional field.
So the partner may
have added a device
IP or some contextual
information that's
useful for them.
And we want to capture that.
But if they added
an additional field,
we may fail on our
insert into BigQuery.
So we're going to
have to account
for that within our pipeline.
So there's a couple of things
that BigQuery and Dataflow--
are a couple of features
of BigQuery and Dataflow
that allow us to do
this fairly efficiently.
BigQuery allows
for schema changes
which are additive
within the same table.
So schema changes happen
online and require no downtime.
And the BigQuery
sync within Dataflow
allows the retrieval
of field inserts.
Combining all these
things together,
we can actually achieve
this dynamic mutating schema
within our pipeline.
If we were to look at
our pipeline again,
we may add in the
getFailedInserts inserts
when we're writing
out to BigQuery.
This allows us to retrieve
everything that has
failed insertion to BigQuery.
Then we may invoke
a function which
dynamically mutates our schema.
So everything that failed
to insert, inspect it, add
the additional
field to BigQuery,
and then pass it downstream,
and then finally writing
those mutated records out.
Now this allows us to do
this fairly efficiently.
So alternatively what
we could have done
is we could have inspected
every single message which
enters our pipeline.
And that's fairly
inefficient because you're
doing an operation on
a bunch of elements
that you may not need to, right?
The schema change may
only happen occasionally.
And so you're just adding
overhead to your pipeline.
So as opposed to doing that,
reacting to the failed inserts,
and then mutating the
schema dynamically,
and then rewriting those
records out to BigQuery
allows us to have
efficient, dynamic mutating
schemas within Dataflow.
So if we were to look
at our pipeline again,
how does this look?
We have messages that
may have mutated schema.
And essentially we've
added a whole new path here
in which errors come
out, and then we validate
and we mutate that
schema, and then
we re-output it to BigQuery.
And so without having to have
this complexity of managing
changes with our partners,
we're able to react
to it automatically
within our pipeline.
Another common use case is
real-time denormalization.
So in order provide a summary
view in our data warehouse,
we may want to look up reference
data before we output events.
In our mobile gaming
use case, this
could be looking up reference
data like on the user
or on the partner, adding
contextual information that
will help us do
our analysis later.
In order to
accomplish this, we'll
need to add an additional data
store to our architecture.
In this case, we choose Bigtable
because of the scalability
and latency requirements
that we may have.
If our game is popular, we
may be processing thousands,
hundreds of thousands, or
million events per second,
so we need something
that can scale to that.
Before we implement
the per-record lookups,
we want to consider both the
performance of the database,
so if we're doing
this within GCP,
we're going to prefer
Bigtable or Datastore to do
these per-record lookups because
they'll give us the performance
metrics that we need.
If we were to reach
out to BigQuery,
it would be quite a bit
slower because you're
talking on the orders
of seconds as opposed
to on the orders of
tens of milliseconds
for each individual look up.
And we also want something
that scalable, too.
Because if we put, let's say, a
single postgres instance to do
our lookups, Dataflow
is like a cannon
we shoot at GCP products.
And so you can easily make
a single instance fall over.
So we want to keep
that in mind when we're
doing our per-record lookups.
And finally, we
also want to utilize
the right areas to initialize
and tear down our connections.
ParDos within Dataflow
have a lifecycle.
And I'll speak to that
lifecycle in just a second.
But essentially, we
want to make sure
that we're initializing and
tearing down these connections
in the proper place
within our pipeline,
so within the @Setup
method of the Do function
and within the @Teardown
to close the connection.
So we're going to look
at the ParDo lifecycle.
This is sort of a
crude representation
of what it might look like.
We have @Setup, StartBundle,
and ProcessElement.
And then we also have your
FinishBundle and Teardown.
So where do we do our connection
initialization and teardown?
We're going to do that
in setup and teardown,
just like it sounds like.
And the reason being is
because it's executed once
per DoFn instance.
So as these functions are
distributed across your worker
pool within your job,
it's executed once,
and so you don't have a ton of
setup and teardown connections.
It is rather expensive
to create new connections
and tear them down all the time.
StartBundle and FinishBundle
are executed once
per bundle of records,
so within the pipeline,
Dataflow will actually
bundle records up and then
process them to each transform.
And this allows it
to be more efficient
and not have to
materialize the output
for each individual record.
And we could have
done it here, but this
would be executed a lot more
frequently because there's
going to be a lot more
bundles within the pipeline
than there are
instances of the DoFn.
So this would be a decent place
to actually initialize and tear
down our connections,
but it would not
provide the performance
that we would like.
And finally, we have the
ProcessElement method,
and this is executed
once per worker.
If you do really expensive
things in the ProcessElement
method, this is where you
can slow down your pipeline.
So for instance, initializing
connections and tearing them
down, if you're doing that
for each individual record
and you're processing
records at hundreds
of thousands or
millions per second,
you are going slow down
your pipeline quite a bit.
And so that's why
it's pretty critical
to connect and tear
down your connections
to do these external
lookups in the correct place
within your DoFn.
So zooming in on
our pipeline again,
we want to enrich data
from an external store.
And essentially
we just have added
a couple of different methods
to the Enrich Messages DoFn.
Essentially now we're
in the @Setup method.
We're initialising
that connection.
We're calling a method to enrich
the record, which will then
call out to our
external data store.
And then in our
Teardown method, we're
closing down that connection.
And this allows us to have
efficient per-record lookups
within our pipeline.
And if we were to look at what
our pipeline looks like as we
add in this functionality,
essentially we
have this additional lookup
here connecting to Bigtable,
doing the per-record
lookup, enriching the data
with either user data or partner
data for our game events,
and then passing
that data downstream.
So now that we've done a lot
of the common functionality
that we may have
to our pipeline,
we may want to perform
analysis on the data that's
moving through.
So this is where we
may want to utilize
some of the windowing techniques
that I had mentioned earlier.
So here we don't need to add
any additional components
to our architecture because
windowing is handled
within Dataflow itself,
so there's nothing
that needs to be added here.
And for our analysis,
as I alluded to earlier,
we want to do some analysis to
perform, how long has the user
spent playing the game?
We may also want
to possibly know
when the user stopped playing.
We may want to do things
like, for a session,
group together all of the
events and then compute
and output one aggregate record
that contains an array using
BigQuery's nested and repeated
fields to our advantage.
And so here we'll
actually do the,
how long has the user
spent playing a game?
Now if we were to
use fixed windows,
we inherently have
problems because we
may have family members
that use the same device.
And so if we were just
to group by fixed windows
of a period of time, from like
12:00 to 1:00 or something
like that, we may
actually end up
with different individual
users within that time period.
And so that would
throw off our analysis
of the count of messages that
were seen per user or even
any additional
analysis that we're
doing on the user behavior.
So this would have
incorrect correlations.
What we really want is
to utilize the sessioning
that I had mentioned earlier.
Because with session windows,
what we would achieve
is what we really want.
We basically group together
the events by a key,
and that key being a
user ID, for instance.
And then we're able
to get all the events
for a particular
user into one window
and then compute aggregations
and do analysis on that window
before passing that
data downstream.
And so this gives us exactly
the subdivisions that we want.
So looking at our pipeline
code, we window the sessions
with a gap of five minutes.
So essentially, we are going
to look at bursts of activity,
and whenever we do not see
activity for five minutes
we'll close that window
and we'll fire it off.
And that will trigger the
aggregation downstream
in our processing.
After that, we're going
to key by the user ID.
So essentially we're going to
take that game event coming in,
and then we're going
to get the user ID.
And this actually
creates a key value pair
that we can then group by.
So essentially we're
keying these records
before we group them so
we can get the records
into the right place.
Then we're going to
group by those records,
so we're going to
group by that key
that we have with
the game events.
And that's basically going
to create a grouping of a key
to an array of all
the records that
map to that key
within that session.
And then finally, we're going
to call a method, or a class,
which is going to
analyze our events.
So within this class, we can do
the counting or the averaging
of those records.
We can do the behavior
analysis that we want to.
And really, we can
do any analysis
that we see fit
for our use case.
So now looking at
our updated pipeline,
we have this whole new path.
After converting to rows, we
output to session windows.
We key by the user.
We group by the key, and
then we analyze the events.
And it all happens before we
pass it downstream to BigQuery.
So in this example,
what we did is
we deduplicated records
using exactly-once.
We handled bad data.
We handled mutating data.
We handled enriching data in
real time with these records.
And then we also were able
to then window these records
into meaningful windows
for our use case
and compute analytics
that we preferred.
And so now I'm going to
hand it over to Oliver
to talk us through
Dataflow at Sky.
OLIVER TWEEDIE: Just
to introduce myself.
I'm Oliver Tweedie.
I'm director of data
engineering at Sky.
And for those people who
have not heard of Sky,
we're one of the leading
TV companies in Europe.
We've got 22 million subscribers
across the UK, Italy, Germany,
and Austria.
And we're a quad play provider,
so we do TV, broadband, phone,
and mobile services.
And we selected Google
in 2017 primarily
for its data capabilities.
So we spent about four months
getting Google Cloud set up
for Sky and designing
our target architecture.
And we've been up and running
and live for eight months now.
So we consider GCP to be
a great data and analytics
platform as a service.
So today I am going
to talk about Sky Q.
Now Sky Q is our
flagship TV platform.
It's a TV box, and we think
it offers one of the best TV
experiences in the UK in terms
of quality of the platform
and the range of content
available for the box.
So Sky Q has a satellite tuner.
It does video on demand.
It does live streaming.
It does HD and UHD content.
And what we do is we collect
diagnostic data from Sky Q
boxes in every customer's
home, and that's
sort of three million
boxes at the moment
as live in the field.
So we want to collect
diagnostic data so we
can understand user journeys.
We want to be able to
optimize those user
journeys so our
customers can find the TV
content they love easily.
So that means fewest clicks
or shortest searches,
easy-to-navigate UI,
promotions, and personalization.
So for example, someone
clicks on the Home menu,
they go to Movies, they select
a genre, they find the movie,
they press Play.
So our original solution
for Sky Q analytics
was based on a Hadoop cluster.
It was a fixed-size
cluster on-prem.
And Sky Q, great product, really
successful, but the problem
was that we had to deal
with lots of peaks of data.
So TV diagnostic data has
large peaks, so in the UK,
we don't have the weather of
California, unfortunately.
It rains a lot.
When it rains people go indoors.
They watch more TV.
They generate more
diagnostic events.
Also we can have news events.
We can have sports events.
And on those days we get
more diagnostic events.
So the problem with
our fixed-size system
is that we have
to over-provision,
so effectively if
we're provisioning
to the yellow line, we have a
lot of capacity that's wasted.
Whereas, in worse case, we
under-provision the system.
And that means our batch
processing or real-time jobs
take longer.
Or worst case, we
lose data altogether.
The other problem
that we had was
that we spent a lot of time
changing our Hadoop cluster.
I don't know how many people
in the audience run Hadoop,
but our ops team spent time
tuning YARN on a regular basis
and dealing with
managing YARN containers.
We had a platform
with mixed workloads,
so it's very difficult to
get those workflows correct
when things changed over time.
So not a big surprise,
we moved to GCP.
And our architecture is designed
around Pub/Sub, Cloud Dataflow,
and BigQuery.
The reason that we
chose this is it's
Google's canonical architecture,
so really good integration
between all those components.
And we took the opportunity to
move the pipeline from batch
processing to streaming because
our modern Q boxes report back
in real time over IP.
And the other thing
is that we chose
to use Dataflow to gain the
benefits of autoscaling,
serverless architecture, and
out-of-order data processing.
So much like Ryan's
example with mobile gaming,
people turn off our
TV boxes at night.
Quite often we get
data turning up late.
So out-of-order data processing
is really important to us.
So features in the Beam
model, really important,
and we also think the Beam model
is becoming much more mature.
And we like the
sort of separation
between the runner and the SDK.
I think it's a good thing
to be able to abstract
the data pipeline itself
from the infrastructure
or the runner.
So moving on to talk
about our architecture,
effectively what we do here is
we take data in streaming mode,
in the ingest stage.
So it's JSON data, just like
in the mobile gaming example.
We take it from our
Q box into Pub/Sub.
Separately we take reference
data, batch mode into GCS.
So then in our process
stage, what we do
is process this in Dataflow.
So in the streaming
path, we clean the data.
We add additional attributes.
We assign join IDs.
We sessionize the data,
so session windows.
We turn a sequence
of user events
into distinct TV sessions.
And these are enriched with
session IDs, start times,
and the event
number of sessions.
So we think that the
ability to dynamically add
columns in BigQuery
when our JSON schema
changes is a great feature,
and we make use of this.
So this means we can
have non-breaking changes
with the source system.
So our source system
team just adds an element
to the JSON message, and that
manifests itself in BigQuery
as a new column.
So what we've got
is also a separation
between our first stage of
processing and enrichment.
And the reason
that we do this is
that we use our granular
data for multiple use cases.
And we don't always want to be
able to use the enriched data
in those separate use cases.
So we have two stages of
processing in our architecture.
So in the enriched
stage, what we do is
we create this notion
of Q box journeys.
And these box
journeys add things
like the customer details.
They add information around
how the planner works
and different
reference data relating
to the tiles on the UI.
So for example, we can see
then that somebody started
searching for data on the box.
They found "Game of Thrones."
And then they started
watching "Game of Thrones"
and engaged in a big "Game
of Thrones" TV marathon.
Finally, we display
all this in Tableau.
So we've got a
number of aggregates
that sit under Tableau and allow
Tableau to perform effectively
and give everyone really
kind of snappy performance.
So again, like in the example
that Ryan was talking about,
we make use of sessioning
for our TV events.
So Sky processes sessions
based on a continuous stream
of diagnostic events.
Each one of those is calculated
for an individual Sky Q box.
And we do this based on a
four-hour gap of inactivity.
So essentially what we're
looking for is that four-hour
gap of activity and then
everything in that window
before it becomes a session.
We've got a hard cutoff
after 24 hours on the basis
that we think no one watches
TV for more than 24 hours.
So we also make
use of autoscaling.
So autoscaling
happens transparently,
but interestingly the
rules for autoscaling
are quite sophisticated.
So don't expect autoscaling to
happen immediately when there's
an influx of new work to do.
Sometimes it takes a while
for Dataflow to scale up,
and that's because it's got
a sophisticated heuristic
in the background
working and optimizing
the number of workers in
the Dataflow pipeline.
So essentially, it
might add workers
to keep up with the input rate.
So it knows the amounts
of unprocessed work
in Pub/Sub or the queue depth.
And it might also need to
catch up with the backlog.
And it's smart
enough to understand
the rate of processing
and whether it's worth
scaling up those extra
workers to process
that backlog of work.
So sometimes it
might not scale up
because it will realize that
by the time you've scaled up
and added more workers,
the work would be done.
So what we've got
now is a situation
where we can process many
hundreds of millions of records
without having to manage
any of the infrastructure
and be able to cope with those
peaks entirely dynamically.
So we're regularly processing
more than 300 million messages
per day, in some cases
now well over 400 million.
It's been a great
success in the business.
It only took five weeks to
develop this solution from end
to end.
And we agonized a
bit about whether we
should port our existing Apache
Spark code over and run it
on Dataproc.
And we think we made
the right decision
not to do that and rewrite
everything in Dataflow, just
because we've taken
all the benefit of not
having to manage the cluster.
We also partnered
with Datatonic, who
we may have in the audience.
But Datatonic are experts in
data engineering and machine
learning.
And they were able
to get our team up
to speed with Apache Beam,
Pub/Sub, BigQuery really
quickly.
We do A/B testing
on the box software,
so we can determine whether,
from one release of the Q
software to the next,
that we're actually
seeing material benefits and
improvements in the software.
So typically what
we do is we take
a small population of boxes,
we roll those boxes up
to the new revision,
and we watch
whether both old and
new cohorts of box users
are performing as
we would expect
and whether the new cohort
is seeing a material benefit.
And in many cases,
we can now find
that we're seeing more than
double-digit improvements
in performance of the
UI and user experience.
So a quick summary
of before and after--
so before we had an
on-prem Hadoop cluster.
We had to manage network,
servers, software upgrades.
We had to patch everything.
We had a lot to maintain.
Now we've got a completely
serverless as a service model.
We can scale in no time
at all, like 90 seconds,
to add more workers.
Whereas before, we
were talking months
to add new servers, where we may
have to even put in a request
to finance and deal with all of
the capital expenditure outlay.
So it's high fixed costs
with the existing solution,
and now we can just
pay for what we use.
One of the biggest improvements
has been in development time.
Before, with the fixed-size
system on-premise,
it was almost impossible
to recreate that production
workload, especially with
multiple workloads running
on the same system.
So development time
took a long time
because it was very difficult
to test things and replicate
the production workload.
Now we can replay all our
messages back into Pub/Sub,
through into Dataflow and
into the new developed
version of our pipeline.
And it's very much, very
much simpler to test.
And that's meant
that development
now happening in
weeks, not months.
And ops are delighted.
Rather than spending two
days a week tuning YARN,
its near zero ops.
So again, great success for
Sky and also a great success
for the business.
So Dan Chronnell, who heads
up our product experience,
now feels that this is an
extension of the product design
and development capability.
So he says, "This
capability has the power
to change the way we
develop our products
and has made me very proud of
what we've built together."
And finally, I'd just like
to say a couple of thank yous
to Datatonic, who partnered
with us to build this,
and also Agile
Solutions, who helped
do some of the
project management.
So thanks to Louis and
Andrew on the technical side
at Datatonic, and Stephen
from Agile Solutions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]